مستبقا للجميع افتتح دونالد ترامب حمله
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
متحديا الجميع داخل وخارج حزب هل يؤكد
ترشحه ان المعركه داخل حزب الجمهوري ستكون
طاحنه برغم ان غالبيه استطلاعات الراي
ترجح فوز ترامب في الانتخابات التمهيديه
للحزب الجمهوري موقف اعضاء الحزب من خطوه
ترامب تتضارب رغم الوعود برسم صوره مثاليه
لامريكا جديده في المرحله المقبله
فالجمهوريون يرون بان ترامب لن يكون قادرا
على لاعب ادوار سياسيه مهمه في المرحله
المقبله بسبب الفشل الذريه الذي تم تسجيله
في الانتخابات التجديد النصفي فراغ مع انه
لا يزال يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره الا ان بعض
الجمهوريين بانه كان السبب في التصدعات
التي يشهدها الحزب بدعمه لبعض المرشحين
دون الاخر في الانتخابات الاخيره فترام
ولد اعلانه عن ترشحه انتقد سياسه الرئيس
اتهموه بالفشل في اداره البلاد وبانه
السبب في التردد الوضع الاقتصادي وارتفاع
وتيره التضخم غير ان بيدن رد بالقول ان
ترامب خذل بلاده خلال توليه منصبه وخلال
رئاسته تربع على اقتصاد مزور لصالح
الاثرياء وهاجم النظام الصحي ودلل
المتطرفين وهاجم حقوق المراه وحرض
العصابات العنيفه
ان يبقى الوضع على ما هو عليها قبل عامين
كنا امه عظيمه وقريبا سنكون امه عظيمه من
جديد
بان المرحله المقبله ستكون ساخنه وصعبه
لدى الجمهوريين خصوصا وانا الحزب يشهد
فوضى كبيره على الصعيد الداخلي فخذت ترامب
وفقه وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه عرضها
العديد من الجمهوريين الذين دعاه لتاجيل
اعلانه الترشح الى ما بعد جوله الاعاده في
مجلس الشيوخ في جورجيا الشهر المقبل غير
انه تجاوز كل الاستشارات التي قدمت له
فترام هذه المره لا يستهدف فقط بيضا
مراقبين فليسعى ايضا لتحطيم فرص منافسين
المحتملين بمن فيهم ديسانتس ونائبه السابق
وبالتالي فان اشد حلفاء ترامب سيرفضون
تقديم الدعم والتاييد له في المرحله
المقبله كما ان تسربت ايضا معلومات تفيد
بان وزاره العدل الامريكيه تريد توجيهتها
من الرئيس السابق ترامب قضيه الوثائق
السريه التي قد تعرقل مسار حملته
الانتخابيه المقبله
[موسيقى]